ERIC ROBERSON: I want to
do something special.
I want to do something
special.
We are live on air, and we have
a lot of companies here.
And I want to do something
special.
I want to write a song possible
right this very
second on this spot.
Me and my good friend, Ian.
But I want to include
you guys as well.
And see, this is how special
it's going to be.
Check this out.
The song is going to be such a
hit that American Express is
going to pay for it.
And they're going to put
it on a commercial.
We're going to make
a ton of money.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: And I'm going
to share the proceeds with
everyone in the room, 'cause
I'm a fair kind of guy.
All right?
But there's a simple thing,
there's a simple
rule you need to follow.
I need subjects.
Words, thoughts, whatever's
from the crowd.
I need whatever.
But before you yell something
out, let the word you yell out
be a fun word.
Do not give me a boring.
We're trying to impress
American Express.
Do not give me a boring,
whack, simple word.
Don't give me love or peace
or fate or intimacy or
anything like that.
I need good words like
toenail clippings or
something like that.
The better the song, the
better our chances that
American Express will
pay for this!
If you decide to still give me a
simple word, trust me I have
a cordless microphone.
I will turn the cameras off
and I will throw this mic.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: As hard and as
accurate as I can into your
chest cavity.
OK?
All right, any words,
any words.
Anything?
AUDIENCE: Lilacs.
ERIC ROBERSON: You
said lilacs?
Lilacs.
Is that a flower?
It's a flower?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: Wow!
Imagine what's on your mind.
Lilacs.
What color's a lilac,
just so I know?
AUDIENCE: Purple.
ERIC ROBERSON: It's purple.
Thank you very much.
What'd you say over here?
AUDIENCE: I didn't say it.
He did.
ERIC ROBERSON: What
did he say?
I'm not going to use it.
I just need to know
what he said.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: Excellent.
Look at you.
Thank you.
Is that why you're bent over?
OK, I gotcha.
I gotcha.
It's cool.
He's like, ugh!
In fact, [INAUDIBLE]!
You're disqualified.
Anything over here?
Brazil?
I love it.
I'll tell you a quick story.
My wife went to Brazil.
My wife went to Wharton and
they did a school trip.
And she came back and
I was at the airport
to greet her, happy.
And as soon as she got off the
plane, the first thing she
said to me was, you're
never going there.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: That's
a true story.
That's a true story.
So I'm gonna sing this
song in honor of my
absence from Brazil.
Anything else?
Google?
Thank you!
Cha-ching!
We're going to get that money.
[LAUGHS]
What's that?
Roller coaster.
OK, I think we're good.
Are we good?
I think we're good.
Listen, I'm gonna
write this down.
And I usually remember this.
But I'm gonna write it down
because I need you guys to
remember it.
So we have roller coaster.
Just writing roller 'cause
we don't have time.
What was the other ones?
Look, I forgot that fast.
Google.
Lilac.
How do you spell lilac?
What is that?
I never spelled--
oh lord.
Just the one young lady
with the chain.
What's that?
You want your spell to be--
oh, plural.
You want to do lilacs.
OK, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
And Brazil.
OK, are you ready
for the song?
OK, OK, so we have--
what was your word
though, Julie?
I'm gonna take your word.
What was your word?
It was investment?
All right, all right.
She's all corporate.
[MUMBLES]
Investment.
We are in a room full of lawyers
and entrepreneurs.
CDs are only $10.
You can make the investment.
OK, OK.
I apologize.
I apologize Ryan, for
my silliness.
Someone slipped something
in my tea, I think.
OK, so we have--
I could have wrote
roller coaster--
roller coaster, Google, lilacs
plural, Brazil and investment.
Camera, where's the camera at?
I just want make sure
that they see this.
OK, all right.
And Ian's gonna create
the music right now
on the spot as well.
So he's gonna get some
publishing as well.
So you can start it
whenever you feel.
If you want, I'll throw even
a beat to it as well.
But we'll let you start first.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
ERIC ROBERSON:
[PERCUSSION SOUNDS]
That's for the Brazil.
I like this.
[PERCUSSION SOUNDS]
Roller coaster.
Google.
Lilacs.
Brazil.
And investments.
I might even throw
your Ex-Lax in.
I might do it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
[PERCUSSION SOUNDS AND GUITAR]
ERIC ROBERSON: [SINGING]
Let me tell you about a story
when I was laying on my sofa.
How the girl had my heart
go up and down
like a roller coaster.
And I don't mean to say that
like that's a good thing.
But you gave me the word, so
there's a song I need to sing.
I'm from Jersey.
She was from Brazil.
It's hot there.
I live where it's chill.
I tried to say I love you.
I offered her daffodils.
She said, that's whack.
So I brought her some lilacs.
And she let me in,
and I entered.
It was lovely, most
of it, I remember.
See, I thought this girl
was heaven sent.
From that point, I was ready
to make an investment.
I went to go buy a ring.
I even knew the size.
She showed me what she liked.
I checked out the
price on Google.
That's expensive!
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
ERIC ROBERSON: [SINGING]
Wish she was frugal.
So I bought it anyway.
I ignored the danger signs.
Went with my heart
and not my mind.
So I got on my knee while she
was laying on my sofa.
Won't you be with me
for my ride through
life's roller coaster?
And she said yes, softly
laid down tears and
dropped down on my chest.
And I replied by putting my
hand right on her thigh.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
ERIC ROBERSON: [SINGING]
Get your mind out the gutter.
So we fought about the wedding
plans and everything and how
we would have wine
that was chilled.
And we would walk and I would
carry her through the house
holding her up and
we would have a
honeymoon out in Brazil.
And I mean, she would walk down
and the flower girl would
be looking beautiful throwing
purple lilacs.
Until I found out that the
price for weddings put my
American Express to the max.
What I thought was heaven sent
has turned into a bad
investment.
Now I'm looking at all
my money has went.
Seems like all of my money's
really spent.
Next time I'll find
someone frugal.
So I won't have to find out
about bankruptcy in Google.
Hopefully next time I'll
find someone frugal.
Maybe I'll find a dating site.
Let me type it in on Google.
Singleblackman.com.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
ERIC ROBERSON: [SINGING]
Singlewoman.com.
That's [INAUDIBLE] that.
Yeah, applause.
What was that?
I turn to the wrong
website I think.
Go back!
Had a bald headed guy
in a Speedo and in
his mouth was a lilac.
So this moral of the story
before I'm done.
You need to really find who you
invest in, it's not all
about just fun.
Because this young lady
may take your heart
and not give it back.
And your heart will feel
like you just took a
whole bunch of Ex-Lax.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you very
much, ladies and gentlemen.
[APPLAUSE]